I could go on for hours about things to
think about with passwords maybe the top
two is that initially that
um a password needs to be unique on
every different site and the reason for
that is that if you share a password if
you use the same you know your your
kid's middle name has the password on
three different sites and any one of
those gets broken into now the attackers
know your password to use elsewhere and
unfortunately for many of us you know
there are these rules you need to use
capital letters and symbols and
punctuation and numbers and it becomes
impossible to remember so what many
people do is they come up with one
strong password and then use it
everywhere and that's really a bad idea
because again You're vulnerable if it
gets reused if any of those sites gets
compromised now it's out there in the
open so instead what we recommend is to
use a password manager which is an app
that remembers and then autofills
wherever you go we have the Google
password manager it's built into Android
it's built into Chrome but other OS
makers other you know vendors have their
products there's third-party ones that
are both free and paid
again you know you might get what you
pay for so don't just take anything out
there but if it's coming from Google if
it's coming from one of these big
companies that's much much better than
memorizing and reusing that same
password in multiple places
and that makes a ton of sense I mean
when we talk about the passwords for
different websites but what about you
know getting into your your device or
you know your smart watch or whatever
um you know and now you have other
options you can there's Biometrics your
thumbprint or your face scan and all of
that does it matter or is it hey this is
pretty low risk that you know some spy
from another country is going to get
access to my phone so I should just you
know it's just really to keep my kids
out yeah so I mean it depends for most
of us what we're dealing with on device
screen locks is that I left it in a taxi
or a roommate or family member picked
this up and so then the threat model is
pretty constrained and it generally is
okay to reuse
um you know to use a simple pin or a
biometric now you do have to think about
who else has access to it in my own
household I have very smart kids they
watch Khan Academy videos they've
learned a lot and so if I set the same
thing for my watch my wife's watch my
tablet my phone and they shoulder surf
any of those we have that same problem
of you know once once it falls in one
place it goes everywhere for the most
part though I'm not that worried about I
have to say my oldest son if there was
like an Olympics for this he would be a
medalist he can't help it he knows he
but if someone if you're in the room he
somehow knows exactly what you typed in
so anyway yes beware and he I think he's
a Force for good but there might be yeah
I mean foreign spies and 10 year old
kids like there's a you know interesting
Venn diagram there